hi jacko i'm being told in jiu-jitsu
that i'm using too much strength
to execute techniques and dominating
roles
i get after it in the gym and try to be
stronger and fitter
i already limit my strength against same
weight training partners and
definitely don't pull don't bull rush or
overpower lighter partners i want to
improve my jiu-jitsu knowledge and
understand the
intent of reducing my strength and
reducing my strength to learn the skill
but where where is the balance i feel
like i feel like i'm doing
being penalized for working hard and
being strong
and there has to be an element of
strength to technique right
now that i'm trying to do zero strength
working weak positions and they still go
on me i'm not learning anything right
this is what he's asking
what is what is my 25 stronger than my
training partners one hundred percent
i've trained nogi for four years but
ghee only for 12 months
don't judge a white belt warrior
okay so you know
i don't think anyone is saying use zero
strength right
and just be a i used to have a uh kids
in the kids class that would just like
flop around
like use no they'd be like noodles you
know especially when you're a partner
right and i'd say hey don't be that so
no one's telling you to use zero
strength that's not the
that's not the the goal here you just
want to use less strength
and i'm the same way man i work out so i
can be strong
and when we're rolling if i have to use
strength i'm gonna use it
you bench pressed me off off you the
other day from across side wall
technique
yeah yeah
[Music]
you even claimed it at the top you're
like that's all weight lifted
yeah so so that's good right and you you
used it because you had to use it you
were gonna get punished and you're like
oh no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna have
jocko across the side this is early in
the role so boom
got bench press people were watching too
but yeah yeah so
so yeah we we want to be strong for sure
but i'll tell you this is
a key thing when i'm going to train with
someone i'm going to use
just enough skill and strength
to stay slightly ahead of them just
enough
am i trying to crush them
if someone's and i'll tell you if
someone's way lighter than me
then but they have kind of equivalent
skill then i'm going to try and limit my
strength as much as i can so it's
jiu-jitsu versus jiu-jitsu for sure
but i'm definitely going to use my
strength
if needed for really for a couple
reasons the first reason is because of
ego
sure right i don't want to tap i don't
get caught in a bad position i don't
like that
yeah you know if you can't if you train
like
when we're done training i'm definitely
using strength because i'm dripping with
sweat
right i mean i'm using physical
attributes
but that's not the only reason the other
reason that you have to use your
strength
sometimes is you don't want to give
people a false sense of security that
hey that worked right even your good
training partners like you don't want to
say oh the guy gets a position so you
just tap right
because he's in a competition or in the
street the person's not just going to
tap they need to do it right
so that's it i guess the bottom
the bottom line is my guess is this dude
is probably using too much strength he's
probably one of those guys that's
naturally really strong
and he works out and he's thinking i've
been training nogi for four years so now
when i put this g
on man i'm angry about it because i'm
falling behind a little bit
so i'm gonna use some strength yeah i
would say man just try
try and relax and just one of my
favorite
pieces of advice to give
relax harder
[Music]
just relax try and flow when you roll a
little bit and it definitely will make
you it'll make you better in the end the
more you relax
the the more the better you'll get in
the end
yeah and certain i found that like
certain guys that's just their
just their method really just strong
yeah and that's how they roll and
they're just aggressive physically
that's how and
i found that they can a lot of times
they can get
more technical right you know but really
that's kind of their their strengths in
a way and that's it's just their way of
rolling and so you guys are the opposite
you know what now that you mention it
some people that are like that they have
like an on and off switch
they're either all on or they're just
super
docile yeah it's almost like you got to
find that middle ground if you can
if you can but people are different like
let's say
um like remember franklin yesterday's
friends
crazy okay consider him where he's gonna
be real technical and flexible and flowy
and stuff and that's his jiu jitsu you
can
he can i need to be more strong and
rigid and aggressive he can train that
but
his default is that flowy flexible way
and and guys who are like this i think
that's going to be kind of their default
they can train
kind of deviate a little bit and get it
more for sure
but that's kind of just their that's
that's the vehicle they have you know
yeah
and it's it's almost like a genetic
thing it's not genetic i know that but
it's it's kind of
it's almost like the foundation of their
franklin was a trip
to roll with because he was
so flexible but not just in a normal way
yeah
you know what is flexible in his his
spine yes
like when you put your weight on him and
he would just like like jellyfish
it was awesome yeah it was like an
octopus that's exactly what it's like
i wish he kept training man he was so
good i saw him pretty not too long ago
yeah yeah he
trained it like occasionally yeah he
yeah he was getting good for a while
yeah really good
still good though still good um but yeah
it's kind of
there's it's more of a mental thing like
if you mentally ha there's drills like
you can do you
remember um jerry loudon was his name he
jammed up his knees but
we used to do this thing he's like hey
let's just flow right and you know
people say let's just flow
so then they're trying to kill you yeah
he wouldn't though he would be like his
flow would be like a fast pace and you
could even try to hold him down and
and he'd just be like falling flying
floyd he would get you in a good
position then he'd get right out of it
into another you know like he was really
good at flowing
to the point where you get kind of tired
because you're moving so much
it's not full speed flow it's almost
full speed though
so i remember doing that a lot with him
and it
really translated when i would roll it
would be like
i felt like that difference in technique
yeah no that's really good i
i do i always do a warm-up round with
andy like that we just go
position position but we're going but
we're going like you know we're just go
we're flowing
yeah that sounds like that yeah but
that's what it is i mean that's what it
is
don't ever do that with dean
okay no i'm serious don't ever you know
don't ever
say listen to him say like hey let's
just get warmed up
because he's not gonna do that yeah he's
going to flow until he's in a good
position he's going to smash you
so don't do it you have to just go hard
no yeah okay
good yeah yeah andy's real good at that
yeah yeah yeah stuff too yeah
but that's a good way though like if you
yeah that's
i see what you're saying that's a good
way to learn to relax more yes
yeah yes yeah when that becomes more
common because
let's face it i mean if you're strong
and you're going into roles and people
if to the point where
people are saying hey you're using too
much strength yeah if you're hearing
that you're getting like getting asked
if you're hearing that from multiple
people
yeah there's an issue man yeah that's
that my point is even though you're
saying
saying hey some people are just that way
don't
accept that like you who the guy that
asked this question
don't accept ekko's thing of saying some
people just that way because that means
you're just going to keep doing it and
you won't get better
because you will the more you relax the
better you get yeah for sure and of
course i don't mean it like that
yeah i know you don't yeah i know i know
you don't but i'm saying like
don't get that misconception that that's
what echo's trying to say
hey you're just that way go with it no
don't go with it listen what echo is
saying when he's saying hey
find somebody to flow roll with and just
let it flow yeah it's gonna be pretty
rare you find a person whose
kind of default method is this and then
by the way i just realized
i don't say flow roll because i was
thinking about what i say to andy or
we don't say it anymore we just do it
but yeah i usually go hey let's get a
warm-up round
a so i call a warm-up okay slow roll
yeah but sometimes sometimes it's just
like a technique sharpener
okay nonetheless let's say he does do
let's say he does do some flow rolling
some drills and gets better at it
i would i would guess
that there is going to be a significant
remainder of his game that's going to be
this aggressive game
okay yes no the dude yeah
holmes is aggressive on the map for sure
another little mindset that might help
is think less competitively
because you know how like a lot of
people and really it's true though
here's the thing this this element needs
to be there where it when it's time to
spar
it should be competitive otherwise it's
like what are we doing you know i want
to
if i want you to be competitive because
i want an accurate look of what it's
like to roll with jocko or a guy like
jacko big strong good at jiu jitsu
whatever
if you're just flo rolling with me and
non-competitively every single time
i'm not getting the work that i need
yeah really no that's that's what i was
talking about
earlier too is that's why you got your
yeah yeah you got to use strength yeah
so it should be competitive but
if someone if people are complaining
you're going too hard you're going
straight up like every role is adcc
yeah on the line life or death you know
kinda more in that direction
the moon giles yeah so if you think
maybe less of that
yeah and understand that this is this is
training if you want to get less
using strength and stuff you got to kind
of train that stuff
ultimately